oui
viens bonsoir bonsoir bienvenue sur
diagonale l'actualité internationale du
jeu d'échecs
cette semaine et loi actualité très
fortes notamment le match du groupe c
milhas qui mais pas uniquement oui il
peut uniquement puisque nous avons
également été au sénat l'inauguration
des tables des chèques ou là nous avons
eu l'occasion de voir des personnalités
people qui s'intéressent au jeu d'échecs
notamment christian poncelet jean pierre
chevènement etienne bacrot cheval loti
ils étaient tous là j'allais lautier
jean becker réalisateur ainsi que josé
giovanni
on a rencontré la championne de france
qui signfie lire aussi le président de
la fédération française de préfiguration
anatolie valzer comme des meilleurs
joueurs français aussi
zohra ben azzouz my parade julie oui qui
était aussi au match détiennent contre
bdf qui nous nous avons d'ailleurs une
très bonne interview de lui on vous
passera tout à l'heure donc match bacrot
millas qui lois qui sont partis c'est
avec
donc la victoire de bidasses qui
justement donc d'une insigne candidat au
titre mondial
c'est peut-être un match un peu
difficile pour etienne mais bon il a
quand même réussi à égaliser un peu le
jeu peut-être un peu
il s'élance mp3 la taxe sur la sur la
deuxième partie oui disons disons pour
être pour rester simple que etienne
bacrot on n'a pas fait un mauvais
résultat
il a perdu le match 3 et demi deux ans
et demi et je vais quand même contre
alexander beliatski un très fort joueur
il venait juste de sortir du championnat
de france ça ils l'ont expliqué très
bien dans les interviews
donc il n'avait pas une mission facile
dans ce match contre alexander beliatski
et le score je trouve qu'il s'en est
sorti de façon honorable disons il a
perdu une seule partie sur une
préparation de bdf qui est il a quand
même tenu cinq nuls c'est à dire que
dont il a montré une fois de plus qu'il
est très solide et qu'il arrive à tenir
un joueur du top niveau mondial assez
facilement alors je crois qu'on a un
petit commentaire en faites sur la seule
formule du match par le père de mode
etienne bacrot prix pourquoi etienne
bacrot fait-il des matchs et non pas des
tournois alors on va voir peut-être si
on peut passer
est ce que notre première voilà on va
passer tout de suite une interview
donnée sur maintenant tant
qu'organisateur ont peut-être la
dernière question qu'est ce que tu
penses de ceux de toutes ces nouvelles
formules puisque donc on sait que si on
gagne ce match ici des nouvelle formule
de championnat comme le chauffeur du
monde avec partie en semi rapide des
matches très rapide à élimination
directe le championnat de france
nouvelle formule ou alors les anciens
open qui a calé le sont les tendres que
tu préfères à ton avis quels sont les
avantages et les inconvénients de chacun
bon personnellement j'ai un petit avis à
donner là dessus mais je crois que là
par exemple la formule des matches ici
donc ils sont qui permettent à etienne
en fait de se poser en match et est très
très très instructive c'est quelque
chose de très formateur c'est le grand
maître dorfman d'ailleurs qui avait
proposé cette idée il ya quelques années
et je crois que c'était de bon conseil
c'est bien entendu différent d'un
tournoi alors maintenant pour revenir
aux nouvelles formules actuelles qui
introduisent un petit peu de la chance
bon je pense que ça certains intérêts
mais je crois qu'à long terme
on reviendra aux vrais formule qui ont
qui ont permis aux échecs de son essor
en fait c'est à dire les les longs
tournois les matchs les matches longs
etc
à partir du moment où on donne la valeur
d'une d'un blitz au départage à une
partie longue
bon je veux dire c'est puis vraiment des
échecs c'est autre chose
d'accord mais à ce moment là on ira un
peu à l'encontre de la médiatisation du
jeu d'échecs dans la mesure où
maintenant avec les l'influent enfin
toutes les 1 nouvelles informations les
nouvelles technologies tout se passe
beaucoup plus vite
donc les tournois rapide éliminations
spectaculaires sont quand même plus
recommandables je sais pas si je pense
que la médiatiser les les matches qu'ils
ont été
et vraiment médiatisé dans le monde des
échecs mais on pense aux grands matches
ce parce qu'ils fischer karpov kasparov
et c'est ça ça a été des vrais
événements médiatiques bon las vegas
malheureusement on en a parlé que dans
le microcosme des échecs et le
championnat de france a été assez
médiatisé cette année pas grâce à la
nouvelle formule grâce à la
participation de presque tous les
meilleurs joueurs français puisqu'il y
avait seulement le remède hoffman qui ne
jouait pas mais joël lautier jouer et
bien sûr c'était important et en plus il
y avait une bonne organisation
d'ensemble avec la venue de karpov
kasparov
bon ça donc ça joue énormément mais
c'était clairement beau tendre et ici
l'organisation se passe bien oui moi je
suis qu'un pion dans l'organisation mais
on a la chance ici d'avoir le support du
du maire d'albert qui est un
nos amateurs d'échecs qui était un
joueur classé et donc qui supporte les
échecs c'est une très bonne chose en
plus bon bain etienne joue dans sa
région
donc c'est c'est bien aussi quoi
d'accord bon bah bravo et puis bonne
chance bonne chance à etienne et merci
d'avoir répondu à cette interview donc
eloi donc la vie du père des cévennes
macro dons qui lui est favorable vous
échec ancienne formule entre guillemets
aux échecs ans une formule c'est vrai
que il a des ailes des arguments les
matches car peuvent kasparov espace qui
fischer ont été grandement médiatisée
je pense pas qu'on peut retrouver une
médiatisation tél avec le système
d'aujourd'hui mais disons c'est un autre
style avant c'était l'ouest au contrôle
l'est ou alors kasparov l'apparatchik
contre karpov bien intégré dans le
système
maintenant on va plus vers la médiatique
mondialisation et plus vers les grands
tournois plus spectaculaire alors je
sais pas les deux formules ont leurs
avantages maintenant pour la justesse du
résultat c'est vrai qu'un match en six
parties donnent moins donc que juste
titre encore en 20 parties va dire qui
est le meilleur des deux joueurs
alors que le championnat du monde
formule actuelle ne dira pas forcément
qui est le meilleur en faut peut-être
trouver un mélange entre ces différentes
formules qui soit adéquate peut être
trouvé comme nicolas d'ailleurs proposé
aussi un un espèce de mixed aussi de
poule le tournoi fermé suivi de match
peut être un peu plus long après dans
les annales dans les qualifications oui
c'est vrai qu'on a on a bien parlé de
toutes ces formules en général moi
personnellement je suis pour les
formules rapides à une nation direct
comme le grand prix de bordeaux dès ce
qu'on peut dire aussi c'est etienne
bacrot organisateurs stéphane vaqueront
donc le père détiennent et aux
organisateurs
oui alors ça c'est vrai que c'est une
bonne chose pour etienne bien entendu
puisqu'il a maintenant une très bonne
expérience en match on a un peu coupé
l'interview de stéphane mais il a
rappelé qu'en même l'historique de ces
matchs ils ont commencé par les vannes à
rognan donc c'était un des meilleurs
juniors avec etienne ils ont aussi
organisé un match à l'ex miss l'offre
avec cornouaille avec hubert qui sont
tous d'excellents joueurs de match donc
et y en a maintenant une expérience
considérable dans tout ce qui est
un contre un pour ainsi dire donc là un
contre un mais cette fois un peu à son
désavantage mais limite on peut obtenir
il y aura peut-être une revanche est
dans l'air une possibilité de revanche
je crois oui peut-être en guise en
slovénie bayonne et enfin bon tout ça ne
nous regarde pas en tout cas à albert
donc une maintenant une tradition de
match chaque année elle pour etienne
bacrot pourquoi parce que c'est en fait
c'était son club d'origine
maintenant je crois qu'on a l'interview
d'un responsable de l'administration de
la ville d'albert oui nous avons
rencontré l'adjoint au maire donc
jean-françois hu qui est l'adjoint au
maire d'auch pour le tout ce qui est
sport dans la ville d'albert voilà donc
si on peut envoyer une interview de jean
pierre de la salle du jeu de paume avec
monsieur jean-françois eu donc qui est
adjoint au maire dans l'âge le cadre de
la jeunesse
la ville d'albert bonsoir monsieur
bonsoir alors première question comment
et pourquoi fait organisez-vous cet
événement autour détiennent et
et donc bien entendu quels sont les
moyens mis en oeuvre par la mairie et
comment souhaitez-vous continuer en fait
etienne est un enfant du pays et on est
très honorée que etienne se souviennent
qu'il y a quelques années il a des [ __ ]
débuté à albert et nous avons souhaité
avec son accord pérenniser en fait
chaque année un match de dimension
internationale
eux qui ont des retombées évidente pour
la ville d'albert économique en
particulier par exemple au niveau de
l'hébergement de la restauration ou même
au niveau de l'image d'une commune donc
c'est vrai qu' on est très honoré et à
l'avenir on souhaite toujours pérenniser
avec etienne bacrot qui est un joueur
d'échecs très prometteur et dont on est
fier qu'il ait pu commencer dans notre
commune sommes donc à terme vous
souhaitez organiser le championnat du
monde entre etienne et son challenger au
mois de mars 2000 nous accueillons le
championnat du monde de billard
alors effectivement nous sommes rodés
aux championnats du championnat du monde
alors effectivement ce d'échec serait un
plus
et avec etienne qui effectivement est
quelqu'un que nous soutenons nous
soutenons bien évidemment ce on en sera
très heureux et bien merci de soutenir
le jeu d'échecs et je vous souhaite une
bonne soirée
merci encore merci d'être venus en citer
d'encre en voilà et loire la cité
d'encre donc albert qui soutient etienne
bacrot donc on me disais ça fait donc
des années quatre ou cinq ans donc que
ces matchs sont organisés peuvent en
tout cas qu'il devrait aficion comme on
dit en espagne pour etienne bacrot dans
sa cité ouailles qui est l'enfant du
pays comme l'a dit jean françois eu bon
c'est vrai que moi je trouve ça je
trouve ça très bien etienne développe
beaucoup de jeux d'échecs symbole on
restait à l'heure du jeu à mon avis il
fait beaucoup de choses il refuse jamais
une interview il est trés il est bien
dans le pré rapport avec la presse ce
qui est je dirais indispensable un peu
comme peter l'écho c'est la nouvelle
génération qui est bien bienvenue dans
son temps que l'été
les anciens russes par exemple qui ont
déjà qu'ils parlaient pas anglais dont
il y avait le barrage de la langue en
plus qui refusait systématiquement les
interviews maintenant on va vers
vraiment ce qu'on a toujours rêvé c'est
à dire savoir ce que pensent les joueurs
savoir ce qu'ils font enfin connaître un
peu leurs secrets les est ce qu'il ya
dessous dans les coulisses du jeu
d'échecs en tout cas un peu plus parce
que connaît tous les secrets s'est passé
pas si facile que ça on va passer
maintenant
donc à la fin de match à la fin du match
en fait loi
qu'est ce qui se passe en général à fin
de match d'échecs justement entre les
deux joueurs d'une partie alors quand le
match est fini on connaît le résultat on
sait qui a gagné qui a perdu et donc on
assiste à la ce qu'on appelle la remise
des prix ou alors on donne aux joueurs
une médaille un trophée ou une coupe
plus c'est bien autour d'une enveloppe
qui est l' enveloppe contenant les prix
les prix voilà donc tout simplement est
ici donc nous avons filmé la remise des
prix de ce match entre je crois que
d'abord avant et loire avant la remise
des prix une fois que la partie est
finie
je crois que les joueurs analysent leur
parti et oui et j'avais oublié
donc oui il ya une analyse de partir et
donc à la fin d'une partie des deux
joueurs en fait voit ensemble les
possibilités qu'ils ont n'ont pas pu
encore celles qui n'ont pas pu donc
jouer dans la partie puisqu'on peut pas
aller loin jouer toutes les parties
possible et donc ils confrontent leurs
points de vue pour voir jusqu'à quel
point la profondeur de jugement était
bonne oui en fait l'idée de l'analyse
est simple c'est pas pas forcément de
déterminer tient raison mais plutôt de
confronter les arguments de chacun comme
est la vérité aux échecs c'est une chose
assez difficile à laquelle peu de gens
ce risque en tout cas enfin ne serait-ce
qu essayer de chercher donc là
simplement on peut confronter deux
opinions et ensuite l'analyse se fait
à tête reposée alors on va voir comment
était une macro et alexandre belov qui
analysent leur parti voilà donc là on
voit on va les deux joueurs en fait donc
si bien l'analyse c'est à dire que deux
joueurs ici confrontent leurs idées dont
ils ont plein détendue où il lie à une
non qui vient de placer ces ora base
michael ealy l'entraîneur détiennent
bacrot qui a proposé un coût mais enfin
ce plan là surtout été filmé sur les
têtes des joueurs l'analyse donc là vous
voyez le sourire dtn c'est beaucoup plus
détendu c'est beaucoup plus détendue
mais évidemment que pendant que pendant
la partie
ce qu'on peut dire c'est qu'on a vu
aussi un ballet alors on n'a pas pu le
montrer la moindre balle et demain s'il
vend à vue midi un bel et demain
puisqu'il y avait un écran géant de
projection qu'on n'a pas montré ici
qu'on montrera dans la prochaine
émission
si si je crois en la vie au début d'un
générique vins génériques et donc qu'on
voyait très bien les mains des joueurs
alors c'était très impressionnant à
l'analyse
quand il y avait des propositions de
coûts assez rapide enfin ça c'est si
vous n'avez jamais vu une analyse entre
deux fours joueurs c'est vraiment un
moment à ne pas manquer où il ya les
mains qui se croisent ils parlent russe
en général et c'est assez impressionnant
à voir alors la pression monte loi parce
qu'on a vu donc le père détiennent on a
vu l'organisation par l'intérieur
monsieur hu qui présentait le match on
vient me voir et à la fin de la partie
on va voir un tel incendie et à l'heure
après la fin de la partie là où c est la
fin du match la remise des prix
et après on aura enfin la possibilité
d'entendre les protagonistes on entendra
les deux protagonistes tout à fait c'est
vrai c'est quand même le plus
intéressant de ce reportage entre alors
en attendant remise des prix donc de ce
grand match
etienne bacrot contre alexandre belov
ski albert qui a duré donc toute la
semaine et la dernière remise des prix
bonsoir alors nous sortons de la remise
des prix de 10 avec la remise de la
coupe donc alexandrina ce qui était très
content je crois est très très content
d'avoir gagné ce match et c c'était pour
lui pas si évident que ça on le verra
peut-être tout à l'heure dans son dans
son interview et vous découvrirez qu'il
est assez humble sur l'échiquier
il est resté cézanne en tout cas il le
dit des choses très très intéressante
alors là là donc la partie suivante
c'est enfin donc l'interview détiennent
pas croire ce qu on peut noter c'est que
on a peu l'occasion d'un temps voting
banco en fait je crois qu'on l'a vu sur
tf1 antenne de là il ya quelques années
et dont il ya trois 3 ans à peu près de
3 en deux ans je sais plus exactement
que quand il avait gagné son titre de
grand maître
et c'était à l'époque le plus jeune
grand maître de l'histoire du jeu
d'échecs à 14 ans et trois mois
oui trois mois je crois donc qu'on
l'avait entendu un petit peu à la
télévision et là on va enfin avoir
l'occasion de l'entendre ce qui n'est
pas une mince affaire
oui en fait c'est un peu en
contradiction avec ce que je disais tout
à l'heure mais etienne et le joueur
moderne mais il est surtout très
concentré sur son jeu quand même il
n'oublie pas l'objectif principal qui
est de la joue aux échecs donc alors les
interviews d'accord mais ni avant la
partie ni pendant le match c'est à dire
qu'il faut le prendre au bon moment où
là il se prête très bien aux jeux
l'interview c'est à dire au général
après le match parce qu'on lie au bon
moment et moi je pense quand le yoga ou
oui puisqu'on lui alors on va voir
etienne bacrot surya bonaly sa mort
albert toujours le dimanche après midi
avec etienne bacrot donc tu viens de
faire nul contre alexander dyovskih la
dernière partie du match et tu perds le
match 3 et demi deux ans et demi quelles
sont tes impressions sur ce match on bat
aujourd'hui j'ai pas eu d'occasions de
prendre l'aventage ont même si j'ai
gardé pendant une vingtaine de coups une
position avec toutes les pièces sur
l'échiquier tout ça bon finalement j'ai
rien pu obtenir et c'est logiquement
qu'aujourd'hui
fait nul mais bon dans le match chez
loupé deux occasions de prendre
l'avantagé en fait dans la première
partie j'avais l'occasion de peut-être
de prendre un bon avantage à un moment
j'ai pas réussi voilà et dans là j'ai
perdu la deuxième en gt gt mal préparée
voilà et manger j'aurais dû revenir au
score dans la 4e j'avais un pion
d'avancé puis vraiment une bonne
position mais voilà j'ai toujours pas
réussi je suis pas concrétisées mais mes
chances et lui il a réussi à aller la
gagner
d'accord donc en fait t'as pas gagné une
partie dans le mode ces cinq nuls et une
défaite
c'est un score assez je dirais en union
entre guillemets quand on a la pêche et
qu'on est jeune qu'on a envie de gagner
qu'est-ce qu'elles le sont tus à tirer
de ce match bon les parties étaient
assez intéressante quand même c'était
pas c'était pas un match ennuyeux
j'ai essayé j'ai essayé de revenir à
chaque fois j'ai pas j'ai pas bien
réussi à prendre l'avantagé avec les
blancs c'est pour ça que le score est
comme ça d'accord et donc dernière
question sur le match on passera ton
actualité
comment est ce que tu t'es préparer pour
le match est ce que c'était pas trop
rapprochée du championnat de france sur
lequel on va revenir bien entendu à bien
sûr c'était s'était rapproché du
championnat de france j'ai pas j'ai pas
eu le temps de me reposer peut-être
comme il fallait
moi je sinon j'ai travaillé
quelques jours avec zohra base my
paraphilie avant le match et voilà
c'était s'était rapproché du championnat
de france mais normalement j'aurais pu
j'aurais pu essayer de faire un meilleur
résultat
oui on peut toujours faire mieux mais
alors on cette année comme tout tout a
réussit à gagner les bermudes en début
d'année de bonne augure
tu n'as pas disparu dans le triangle des
bermudes ensuite tu as gagné le tournoi
de lausanne donc les meilleurs juniors
du monde tu as gagné le champion de
france 99
est ce que tout ça ça fait pas un peu
trop
bah ouais en général on peut dire que
j'ai quand même fait une bonne année
malgré que j'ai perdu ce matin j'ai
gagné trois tournois je n'avais jamais
fait ça auparavant trop tendre dans une
année c'est beaucoup mais bon j'espère
que que je vais continuer à manger j'ai
un match en semi rapides contres judit
polgar à bastia normalement et sinon
pour cette fin d'année je sais pas bien
je vais essayer de monde à bord je vais
me reposer après je vais je vais essayer
de bien comprendre pourquoi j'ai perdu
deux matches puis d'essayer de
m'améliorer encore d'accord donc là tu
vas jouer en équipe de france
enfin que faire le stage d'entraînement
avec marc trotsky à naujac sur mer
donc qu'est ce que tu penses de cette
sélection française dans laquelle tu es
le leader puisque des champions de
france 99
bon ben c'est cette phase et c'est une
bonne équipe bien sûr il ya ya joël
christian bauer d'une david marciano et
et laurent frayssinet non dans l'équipe
l'équipe titulaire
ça va c'est une équipe jeune qui est
assez forte bon casif iosif dorfman
aurait eu sa place quand même oui moi
j'espère que que le stage va bien se
passer et puis après on verra pour le
championnat d'europe par équipes je sais
pas si d'accord en tout cas on souhaite
bonne chance pour le gp d'europe
merci d'avoir répondu à ces questions
alors peut-être un dernier petit mot
pour tes fans
c'est un voeu piège donc etienne bacrot
en tout cas très décontractée pour
l'interview ce qu'on a appris c'est son
actualité prochaine il va donc jouer un
match bastia contre judit polgar oui
contre judit polgar qui est une
spécialiste du jeu semi rapide j'ai dit
que le gars ne joue d'ailleurs
pratiquement plus que des exhibitions
semi-rapide enfin j'ai dans ma tête j'ai
dit aux gars est très très forte en semi
rapides à labatut karpov on se
rappellera la jouer un autre match il
sent que je sais plus contre-pied en
tout cas j'ai dit que le gars joue très
bien ça va être vraiment un très beau
moment des chèques à bastia je sais pas
si on aura des images de là bas de toute
façon on ira filmer judit polgar au
tournoi de golf
on espère en tout cas jean philippe le
gars est ce qu on peut noter on va quand
même faire un peu de publicité portant à
bastia c'est un très très grand tournoi
avec beaucoup de prix et loi qui
commence à devenir donc rendez vous
habituels annuel on peut en parler mais
je crois qu'il ya plus de 400 mille
francs de prix oui c'est la troisième
édition les prix augmentent
régulièrement
bon pour parler chiffres c'est je crois
que c'était 300 mille trois cent
cinquante mille et 400000 cette année
donc ça c'est l'ensemble de l'ensemble
des prix un enveloppe enveloppe totale
des prix donc le tournoi dure trois
jours et le premier le gagnant du
tournoi gagne 50 mille francs
donc pour les joueurs d'échecs c'est des
prix au dessus de la moyenne on va pas
dire le contraire
donc ça attire clairement les meilleurs
joueurs du monde
l'année dernière c'est alexander charlin
qui a gagné donc on n'arrive pas à
toucher le top 10 encore voilà c'est pas
à pas les 10 premiers quand même mais
mais effectivement atteint les 100
premiers il ya beaucoup de monde donc le
tournoi est pérennisée maintenant
puisque ça fait ça va être la troisième
édition ce qui concerne bien moi et puis
évidemment je vous parle pas de bastia
et bastia quoi bastia c'est vachement
sympa donc en âge de jouer j'ai joué les
deux premières éditions en tout cas ça
m'a toujours ça m'a toujours fait très
plaisir d et donc pour la première fois
un match exhibition en fait c'est un
match exhibition comme un frère étienne
match semi rapide d'un jeune théâtre à
bastia bacrot polgar pas rater ça on
essaiera d'y être on verra en tout cas
alors maintenant donc on a vu etienne
bacrot
on va évidemment pas raté l'interview
d'alexandre bella ce qui il faut le
rappeler quand même c'est un des
meilleurs joueurs du monde ancien
candidat au titre mondial
il a été barré de sa route vers le titre
en fait en 83 84 que par le grand
kasparov au sommet de son art ça reste
une grande figure des échecs des années
80 quand il a été cadre uc le champion
du rss ce qui n'est pas ce qui n'est pas
rien quand on sait que l'urss était la
nation est toujours quand d'ailleurs la
russie et nations d'un bar one dans le
monde qui gagnent régulièrement la
championne du monde des nations risoul
m4 d'échec est tout à fait bon alexander
dyovskih c1 c'est un monument du jeu on
ne peut pas vraiment dire plus
donc réaction de ce joueur très modeste
et et en même temps très fort alors nous
sortons de la remise des prix de ce
match etienne bacrot contre l'ex ander
beliatski dans la somme à albert je suis
avec le vainqueur du match
alexander beliatski son mister bean
games match against french olli and what
happens match bourgoin logical
deux matchs ma famille
ok sauf you un de what can you say to
you d'ailleurs une partie que la hat
vice can you give to etienne to improve
qu'ils les vols because we know that
with your experience of match on offre
juste lynch s you can't give a
marilyn john french players were you
next time and the politician chassenon
en hockey 20 kg ou mrnf qui combattent
le chanoine for victory et voilà
alexandre bias qui est loi bichet beach
et wav élections européennes ce qui
forme d'interview on avait donc une
grande une grande chance d'avoir
alexandre bédat ski en interview c'est
sûr que si on est allé les chercher en
russie on aurait peut-être eu moins de
chance de le trouver tout à fait non
mais en tout cas il est il est vraiment
adorable comme personne puisque donc
qu'est ce qu'il a dit sur etienne il a
dit qu'il pouvait pas lui donner de
conseils ce qui est quand même assez
je sais pas trop comment dire mais c'est
vraiment respectueux quoi ça veut dire
oui qu'ils estiment qu etienne sur la
bonne voie et à tel point qu'il estime
qu'il a même des chances de devenir
champion du monde
oui il a dit ça aussi mais je pense que
ça reste bien dans la philosophie de
second champion qui est que le vrai
travail c'est celui que l'on réalise
tout seul donc pas de pas de conseils
extérieurs
simplement il dit à étienne voilà le
mieux c'est que tu découvres tout tout
seul
moi je n'ai pas de conseil à donner je
pourrais t'en donner mais c'est bien
entendu mieux que ceux qui les
découvrent par toi même peut-être 43
mieux et ça reste mieux c'est plus dans
son état d'esprit et en plus on bien
entendu c'est une méthode qui a fait ses
preuves
voilà donc actualité sinon d'alexandria
ce qui en fait pas de tournoi surtout du
jeu en équipe oui oui apparemment il
joue plus trop avec seiler défaut on a
peut-être un peu marre de la tension
nerveuse terrible qui a dans les
dernières ont des tournois dans le jeu
par équipe c'est beaucoup plus
décontractée dans la mesure où on joue
une partie cia toute l'équipe qui est
derrière
c'est quand même un jeu qui est plus
plus adaptée disons au jeu sans tension
je veux décontractée alors beaucoup de
russes
ce match est loin puisque l'entraîneur
détiennent lui-même fait partie d'eux
était dans l'ex urss ça il s'agit d'un
joueur très fort puisque c'est le 14e
joueur mondial
oui il s'agit du géorgien zurab admet
parages il est alors le nom un peu dur
intégré mais donc c'est un joueur très
très sympa souriant et jouer aux cartes
il est trés il est très très très cool
quoi moi j'aime beaucoup ce joueur en
plus il est très fort puisque 14e
mondial c'est quand même assez
exceptionnel d'aucune autre année
tiennent depuis un bout de temps déjà
ça doit bien faire six mois au moins je
me rappelle qu'il était déjà en gains
avec lui on l'avait vu d'ailleurs sur la
vidéo du tournage au gain oui d'ailleurs
on est tout à fait voilà que dire de
plus à part montrer des images voilà
zohrab as my part à gilly
bonsoir donc nous sommes cette fois ci
avec robes à smocks par yachvili
l'entraîneur détiennent bacrot actuelle
et qui la seconde et pour toute la durée
de ce match somistes mappage fait les
good evening soit non c'est china
etienne bacrot official trailer we can
say so you walk wyatt alone with etienne
de yoplait police match
what are you in pression avant ce resort
and what can be mme pauline etienne
splice ce
forfait 5h
il faut sochaux deux périodes
just had two weeks d'un taux fixe to
play le match n 2 qui d'entrée times tôt
benjie after the good the bad and tout
le reste
just a few days to be a star to work
septembre 2006 d abattre un azerty games
with break
question gay games aucun problème
gameloft
ok 2
es-tu normand tout
pour définir solde de ouattara
objectif avant tout maxime washington
and so what this with etienne tout c'est
d'être prêt
winner of sam evans à evanston
tournament est championne de l'exemple
louis se prepare to make you not like to
2 to be
force navale forte civile et seems to be
next gaspard beby les machines keurig
évoqué son vaincu very much robinson de
we hope est furieux voilà l oit
l'entraîneur détiennent qui donnait son
avis sur le match
oui tout à fait alors dont les remarques
intéressantes où il a détaillé un peu
pourquoi etienne a perdu le match
il a dit un principe très juste c'est
que la saison il peut pas tout gagner
il doit perdre de temps en temps il faut
que il tire le maximum de profit de ces
défaites
c'est à dire qu'ils comprennent en fait
tout simplement pourquoi il a perdu et
la phrase finale est assez assez
sympathique c'est je pense que bon c'est
très dur d'être champion du monde il
faut travailler beaucoup
il faut beaucoup de chance mais il a le
talent pour y arriver il a le talent
pour devenir un nouveau kasparov ses
cinquante espèces à la exactement
l'objectif qu'ils essaient de tout cas
de d'atteindre avec avec son élève en
fait son nouvel élève ils ont tout un
programme d'entraînement enfin il
travaille ses a priori travail ils sont
plutôt efficaces à travailler ensemble
intérêts bon c'est en traînant de talons
hauts très fort bon maintenant on va
voir un en tout cas on peut dire que on
peut dire si l'élève dépasse le maître
le maître étant déjà 14e mondial il ya
des chances d'être dans les premiers et
tout à fait non mais c'est un bon
entraîneur et laisser un bout des lèvres
donc une belle combinaison une belle
combinaison alors notre latin en trois
ans portage sur albert se termine mais
en ce qu'on peut dire c'est qu'on a mis
en ligne donc la partie la quatrième
partie où etienne aurait pu revenir
puisqu'il a gagné un client une partie
très tendue
alors je vous rappelle que vous pouvez
regarder cette partie
donc il ya deux façons de la voir vous
pouvez cliquer sur le bouton jouer qui
est à votre droite donc sur l'écran qui
vous amène sur une applet java sur
lequel vous avez la partie donc la
quatrième partie du match bacrot
milevskiy deuxième option et loi c on
peut télécharger en cliquant sur le
bouton pgn le fichier pgn qu'on appelle
porter ball game notations qui permet de
suivre la partie sur des logiciels
oui alors ça ça dépend de votre
plateforme enfin les spécifications
techniques stéphane les connaît mieux
que moi
puisqu'à la base c'est pas ma formation
donc je pense qu'il a tout expliqué
c'est clairement
voilà donc de façon pour vous de voir la
partie soit directement sans en
regardant sur la sur le sur le donc sur
internet explorer ou netscape
donc j'arrive plus à trouver le mot
voire l'applet java ou alors charger le
fichier pgn pour le regarder sur un
logiciel spécifique que vous trouverez
en cliquant sur différents voilà donc
voilà pour la version technique on
n'aura pas le temps et les lois de voir
la partie parce que maintenant on va
voir un deuxième reportage la semaine a
été riche avec un bel événement au
palais au jardin du luxembourg très bel
événement donc à paris cette fois on la
sait plus vraiment du jeu d'échecs
c'est l'inauguration des tables des
chèques mais alors qu'est-ce que ça
permet de découvrir le jardin du
luxembourg déjà très beau jardin
appartenant au sénat avec beaucoup de
joueurs d'échecs c'est à dire c'est un
jeu qui est complètement différent ce
n'est pas un tournoi c'est pas un match
c'est pas un blitz c1 le jeu les joueurs
de jardin ne c'est pas du jeu sur
internet en plus c'est les ans un joueur
qui aime venir ici à cadre agréable
soleil même de forts joueurs qui
viennent aussi il ya même d'autres
forgeot en même temps pour qu'ils
viennent et ça fait donc des années que
ce jardin accueille des joueurs donc
régulièrement on peut aller donc jouer
au jardin du luxembourg
donc le sénat à l'initiative de
de mettre en place des tables
spécialement fait pour le jeu d'échecs
voyant la tradition qui s'était établi
et donc on va retrouver un événement
grandeur nature on va peut-être pas de
détailler plus ces lois et on va
évidemment été très bien mis en relief
très très long mais très bien fait
mousser l'événement et tout le monde
était là tout le monde était là alors
voilà première premier petit passage
vidéo sur le jardin du luxembourg
est ce l'une des raisons qui l'ont
conduit en rejoint vous n'êtes pas des
assassins où j'avais le jardin du
luxembourg et parents d une
traditionnelle des joueurs d'échecs
comme dans beaucoup de parcs publics
dans le bon ou lycées fois que mon bilan
mais curieusement rien n'a vraiment été
beaucoup vous jouez mais tous les
promeneurs dans la présence génère
encore le sénat ne s'est pas aperçu de
nous fait mal et sans vous de l'avoir
choisi pour pratiquer votre discipline
revient en installant c'est à nous avons
voulu d'abord vous avez un mobilier
confortable donc qui on a vu on a vu des
personnalités de premier plan en france
alors nous avons vu le président du
sénat lui-même dont christian poncelet
nous avons vu également
ministre jean pierre chevènement de
l'intérieur ministre de l'intérieur ce
qui n'est pas le plus facile
on a vu aussi etienne bacrot écrit c'est
le pire nos deux champions de france
actuellement 90 féminin et masculin donc
un joli plateau pour l'inauguration
lorsqu on a ce qu'on a vu aussi ses qui
avait beaucoup de monde autour et
beaucoup de télévision beaucoup de
journalistes énormément de public
d'ailleurs il y avait des gradins pour
empêcher que tout le monde puisse will
venir voir hier c'était une très bonne
manifestation beaucoup tous les joueurs
habituels du jardin était là il y avait
toute la presse donc la kiné prix
habituel qui est elle un grosse
effervescence quand même dans les
jardins du sénat pour accueillir ces
personnalités
alors suite à ce discours d'inauguration
d'un christian poncelet convient donc de
voir eloi donc on va voir maintenant
qu'après des partis sont organisés entre
les personnalités
il y avait aussi des cinéastes des
réalisateurs on va voir tout de suite je
crois une partie très intéressante avec
enfin une ambiance de ces différentes
parties et après on commentera les
personnalités que qu'on a pu voir jouer
donc une petite démonstration après 7
ce discours de question qu'on seulement
que l'inauguration d'étape des chèques
pour à proprement parler avec les
premiers joueurs qui les premiers
utilisateurs de ces nouvelles tables
voila voila si on peut passer
si j'obtiens finalement au cou jean
becker
il
on est marin
orapi ici donc on voit on a vu la femme
détiennent de joël lautier ici christine
flir championne de france et là le but
entre jean-claude loubatière à droite
président de la fédération rencontre
machart quoi tu lis ici
alors ici donc jean becker la droite
contre jean pierre chevènement si je ne
trompe pas à gauche et or la voilà le
clou le clou vraiment le le clou de
cette inauguration détail par un juillet
à droite qui joue contre un atelier
weiser championne france 97,1 téléphona
en même temps au téléphone en même temps
alors pourquoi on sait pas ça par les
russes je pense que alexander believe
qui était en train de négocier l'arrivée
voilà prochains temps donc voila voila
ces différentes personnalités
donc on a vu qu'on a vu ici jouer
beaucoup de plaisir je crois et des
personnes qui sont venues comme on va le
voir peut-être un peu plus tard avant
tout pour médiatiser le jeu d'échecs
s'est on se rend compte que beaucoup de
gens en fait beaucoup beaucoup de gens
jouent aux échecs y compris dans des
gens de chez des personnes qui font tout
autre chose
oui ça c'est vrai enfin il y avait un il
y avait des doutes vraiment du beau
monde dans ce jardin
c'était avant tout une c'était très
convivial c'était vraiment agréable
d'être là bas on sentait que tout le
monde était détendue c'était vraiment
une bonne ambiance avec des gens sympas
et des joueurs d'échecs venus de toute
la france de toute la france même de
toulouse
même de toutes normes ont aussi et de
bordeaux de bordeaux tout à fait donc
beaucoup de monde alors on a aussi des
gens qui viennent de montpellier
puisqu'on a vu tout à l'heure
le président de la fédération dont
jean-claude matière qui était présent
aussi donc pour cette inauguration donc
ça a attiré beaucoup de monde on voit
que quand les institutions s'occupe un
peu de du jeu d'échecs mais tout le
monde vient donc on va voir maintenant
une interview du président de la
fédération jean claude delaude matière
oui se chargeant claude dont nous sommes
au sénat avec jean-claude loubatière le
président de la fédération française
d'échecs alors ici c'est un événement
très médiatique et très bon pour les
échecs à priori comment la fédération le
soutien et qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que
vous conseille de cet événement tout
simplement d'abord c'est un événement
qui est très important pour les échecs
parce que les échecs c'est tout c'est
internet qui arrive c'est jouer seul
contrevenant un ordinateur s'est jouée
traditionnellement et puis c'est aussi
joué dans les ordres d'un public avec
les jambes des gens qui aiment les
échecs qui se passionnent qui viennent
voir et donc aujourd'hui c'est une forme
de reconnaissance pour ce type de jeu
qui n'a pas disparu d'accord alors dit
si vous avez donc vous avez été déjeuner
au sénat et donc on est apparemment tous
les gens sont contents vous avez des
biens reçus il ya beaucoup de joueurs
d'échecs
comment un événement comme ça peut-il
être organisé enfin quels sont les
secrets d'une réussite par ailleurs moi
je crois qu'il veut partout il faut qu
et qui en détonateurs un quelqu'un qui
soit motivé bon dans le cabinet dudit
sénat il ya un joueur d'échecs est
motivée qui a été certainement
celui qui a initié le projet est donc
après bon le projet se monte et puis
c'est bien d'accord l'actualité fédéral
pour la médiatisation de la
médiatisation du jeu c'est ça passe par
quoi ça passe par beaucoup de choses
bon c'est un petit peu une question
difficile parce que bon c'est d'une part
les échecs spectacle s'est d'autre part
les échecs chez les jeunes c'est un
internet une des compétitions par
internet
donc il ya beaucoup de beaucoup de
volets et puis c'est bien sûr nous nos
champions que ce soit etienne bacrot
champion de france marie ce bac
championne d'europe des moins de 14 ans
d'accord donc la fédération bien avec
son temps dans les technologies merci
monsieur le batteur donc eloi même le
même le président la fédération était là
et on peut dire qu'il était est assez
content que cet événement oui il a fait
un blitz contre bachar quoi tu lis alors
bachar poli peut-être candidat à la
présidence de la fédération en tout cas
c'est un des candidats potentiels et ils
ont fait match nul dans cette belle
partie il paraît que jean-claude à des
prix avantageux
jean claude a raté un m 2 alors bon mais
c'est habituel pour lui puisqu'il joue
quand même assez bien aux échecs c'est
un passionné du jeu il à 2111 du 2 ce
qui passe quand même un niveau
international c'est raisonnable et
sharko type dont bien entendu et de
remettre des chèques et joue très très
bien donc un match qui était qui était
intéressant peut-être bachar avait fumé
un peu trop de cigares cette fois ci est
donc donc une partie nulle
donc maintenant il reste il reste encore
du monde d'ailleurs on va pas tout
pouvoir tout passé loi puisque on va en
garder un peu pour la semaine prochaine
puisque en fait on pourra pas tout cas
les tellement il y avait de monde mais
il nous reste deux encore des
personnalités très intéressante à voir
notamment encore une fois quelqu'un
qu'on connaît bien puisqu'on l'a vu tout
à l'heure eh bien il s'agit de etienne
bacrot le jeune étienne champion de
france 99 qui a perdu le match en
belgique ce qui donc il était encore là
au sénat avant de partir pour ce fameux
match ce fameux entraînement avec marie
doré tri à naujac sur mer dont on a
parlé pendant l'interview donc la star
française et d'échecs etienne bacrot
deuxième toujours au sénat pour cette
inauguration des tables d'échecs avec
cette fois la star la star de
l'événement etienne bacrot bonjour
etienne saluer loi donc tu es partout
web à albert jardin du luxembourg
bush vaut quoi et alors ici tu es venu
tu as donc d'y manger au sénat avec
toutes les personnalités et là tu viens
de faire des parties contre des joueurs
people célèbre web un repas c'était très
sympa donc avec les gens que je
connaissais déjà un peu et puis là j'ai
fait j'ai fait une partie contre jean
becker j'étais pas positif contre lui
j'ai fait deux nuls en simultané mais
l'a finalement j'ai réussi à m'en
prendrais seulement j'ai gagné la partie
d'accord donc tu te sens à l'aise dans
ce genre de manifestation c'est un bon
ambassadeur du jeu moi peut-être etienne
pas très convaincu bon bah merci pour
cette interview et bravo pour ce que tu
fais pour les échecs web à mercier loi
et bravo à toi pour ton boulot tu en as
lice c'est très bien ouais merci
alors vous demandez moi s'il te chambrer
pas c'est un petit peu ça enfin en tout
cas il est beaucoup plus décontractée
que
l'interview à paraître sur deux d'après
le match c'est normal puisque ses traits
faciaux une partie faut rappeler que les
parties comptent bidasses qui dure en
moyenne 4 heures en fait au moins 24
heures c'est pas facile mais alors là il
était bien souriant et qui chambrent un
peu mais quand même sondage
en tout cas très très sympathique donc
etienne était donc invité par le
président cheney bon en fait ils se sont
rencontrés avant je crois qu'il ya eu un
repas informel enfin il paraît que
c'était d'excellente qualité
l'excellente qualité origines de la
présidence du sénat ça doit être
agréable ils sont tous ressortis avec
des cigares ils devront donc en tout cas
ils ont été bien reçus au sénat par
christian poncet donc l'initiateur en
fait on y viendra après qu'est-ce qu'on
a une autre interview à montrer plus
tard tout à fait pas mal d'interviews
encore intéressantes
après le champion de france on va voir
l'interview internet du numéro un
français depuis des années
c'est le plus fort joueur français joël
lautier il s'agit de lautier sans
surprise bon il est très fort il a raté
son championnat 37 années les autres
tournois lyon bien réussi globalement 99
ça a été une année
un peu de retour de joël lautier après
une grande période difficile il s'est
fait éliminer au champion du monde de
las vegas en huitième de finale contre
boris qu'elle fonde ce qui était donc
pas si facile c'est sa bête noire un peu
donc là joël lautier un peu tranquille
en vacances dans ses jardins et
d'inauguration tout cas voilà je vais
lautier pour la première fois sur
diagonale totalement enfin en visibilité
totale puisque on l'avait passé une fois
uniquement en analyse et on n'avait pas
vu pour un problème de montage
je vais lautié
bonjour alors on est au sénat donc la
première remarque et tu m'as fait en
arrivant ici c'est qu'est ce qu'il ya
comme joueur d'échec c'est
impressionnant qui est ce que tu peux
détailler un peu ce propos oui c'est
vrai je m'attendais pas à ce qu'il y ait
autant de joueurs en plus des joueurs
que qui habite d'habitude ne sont pas à
paris et parce que l'impression qu'ils
se sont déplacés spécialement pour
l'événement donc c'est un peu surprenant
tu viens je ne jouais au luxembourg
d'habitude où tu ça fait longtemps que
je viens plus je venais pas très souvent
pourtant j'habite pas très loin du
luxembourg mais bon c'était pas dans les
habitudes mais je pense que je le
passerai plus haut on fait un tour
d'ailleurs ce week-end en italie où on
peut faire des blitz bon un petit match
de blitz avec joël alors donc un dernier
petit mot vous avez été reçu au sénat
c'était bien ah oui c'était très bien et
c'était très bon aussi on a bien mangé
et en plus sévères de voir que les
échecs bâtir la tension dans des gens
qui peuvent faire quelque chose pour que
le jeu d'échecs se développe eh bien
merci joël et puis bonne bonne fin de
journée
bonjour toujours dans ce genre voilà
donc
on a aperçu juste après christine
fleurent on le passera là on passera
cette interview la semaine prochaine je
vais lautier très décontracté
lorsqu'elle bien et que joël c'est que
même quand les questions sont pas bonnes
les réponses le sont quand même
il a quand même réussi à dire tout ce
qui est tout ce que j'avais envie qu'ils
disent en fait tout ce que je peux et
118 demandes n'étaient pas encore chaud
c'était la première interview de la
journée donc ce n'était pas la plus
facile
ce qu'on peut noter donc là on a vu donc
le champion de france 99 donc etienne
bacrot on a vu jouer lautier mais
évidemment il y avait aussi d'autres
personnes étaient toutes là on a vu
chevènement donc le midi à l'intérieur
évidemment christian poncelet puisque
c'est lui qui est à l'initiative de
l'opération
donc on a vu aussi des personnalités du
show business du show business entre
guillemets enfin oui non même s'il
s'agit de des réalisateurs josé geovanni
et jean becker qui sont vraiment des
fans inconditionnels du jeu comme on va
le voir dans les interviews
oui d'ailleurs c'est pas la première
fois que jean becker rencontré etienne
mais on va peut-être laissé etienne le
soin de raconter pourquoi oui par contre
je sais que je le lotti avait déjà
rencontré josé giovanni
alors cette fois les rôles étaient
inversés puisque c'était josé giovanni
qui commentait son propre film joël
était dans le public et lui a posé des
questions à propos de cinéma donc et
josée gervais ni ne savait pas qui était
ce ce monsieur c'est fatima cieux alors
que finalement c'était joël lautier
quand même donc voilà si on peut passer
maintenant on a une interview donc des
réalisateurs jean becker et josé
giovanni ou donc au jardin du luxembourg
je me rappelle
nous sommes donc au sénat avec nos
réalisateurs préférés
donc jean becker josé giovanni et le
jeune génie français etienne bacrot donc
d'abord une question pour enfin les
réalisateurs vous aimez beaucoup de jeux
d'échecs ça on le sait vous êtes venus
ici c'est très gentil
donc en fait vous êtes venus avant tout
pour jouer ou pour médiatiser le jeu
d'échecs pour médiatiser de jeu d'échecs
d'abord parce qu'on pense que c'est
nécessaire je crois que c'est au niveau
scolaire derrière moi je crois que ça va
devenir plus ou moins une non pas
obligatoire mais mon petit fils par
exemple on lui donne un choix il peut
apprendre à jouer aux échecs à l'école
donc je pense que je crois que c'est une
grande ouverture d'esprit que c'est très
bien que ça apprend à vos enfants à se
calmer par moments et et apprendre j'ai
pas une manière de classification de
l'esprit village
je c'est pour ça que j'essaie de faire
de mon mieux pour essayer de que les
échecs soit plus connue en france
d'accord même chose chez lui pour
médiatiser les échecs parce que je joue
plus depuis un moment mais enfin c'est
une passion pour moi et s'adresse quand
même dans la tête une passion ça m'a
beaucoup appris ça m'a ça m'a calmé
j'étais un attaquant prématuré même dans
la vie un très violent et je crois que
c'était une bonne thérapie pour moi les
échecs
d'accord c'est très intéressant donc les
échecs scolaires les échecs thérapie est
pour toi etienne les échecs passion jeu
ou métiers main pour moi c'est c'est une
passion où j'essaie toujours de
m'améliorer pour faire de bons résultats
voilà je trouve très bien que que des
gens des gens connus nous aident pour
promouvoir le jeu d'échecs est alors pas
de pardon oui heureusement qu'il ya des
gens justement ces récents quand même
qu'il peut y avoir des gens comme joël
comme nuit que mais je veux dire qu'ils
soient comme toi si c'est vrai c'est
vrai ccc avance qu'il n'existait pas ou
on voit très peu il ya eu quelques
joueurs français mais là en ce moment il
ya une recrudescence de jeunes joueurs
français qui montrent leur danse eh bien
voyez alors deux questions une dernière
petite question est-ce que vous avez des
enfants ace qui joue aux échecs
alors j'ai des enfants qui jouent qui
joue un petit peu
j'ai des petits enfants qui jouent aussi
très peu mais quand en vigueur en qu'on
a envie de jouer donc je sais pas si je
vais les pousser à jouer mais en tout
cas à chaque fois qu'ils me demandent de
vin j'aime bien jouer avec eux ça me
fait plaisir aussi manger ma fille qui
m'a tant est grande à 35 ans qui joue
aux échecs jeu après josien qu'elle joue
aux échecs
mon fils j'ai pas pu peut-être avec les
petits enfants les deux plus petits la
toute petite fille veut te deriez du
coup je vais peut-être essayer de leur
apprendre à jouer aux échecs il faut pas
les forcer c'est une passion je me
disais josé c'est à dire que on a envie
je crois que je ne sais pas si je te
pose la question est ce que toi tu n'as
pas forcer à jouer ça t'est venue de
josé sheikh taha bien envie de faire ça
voilà pourtant c'est bien sûr c'est venu
tout seul bien qui vient de lui-même
c'est formidable voilà je dois dire a
ajouté vous savez les échecs aussi bien
dans les sanatoriums les maladies de
longue durée ont sauvé beaucoup de gens
parce que ça les a tirés de leur maladie
ça les empêcher de penser à leur maladie
aussi chez les prisonniers qui en jouent
aux échecs s'évade de la prison ils ne
sont plus dans la prison
d'accord et ben merci beaucoup c'était
très instructif alors j'ai vu que vous
avez joué trois parties que trois ou
quatre parties qu'elles étaient le
résultat non c'est pas la peine de vieux
6e 6e jeu souci si c'était mon élève
c'est moi qui ai appris à gevrey chalet
qui va leur donner le bon merci beaucoup
voilà des lois des passionnés parler
clairement des passionnés en plus des
réalisateurs de talent donc que demander
de mieux pour le jeu d'échecs
je sais pas en tout cas mais peut-être
d'organiser un match
etienne bacrot jean becker peut-être au
palais des congrès à paris tout cas
c'est un four joueurs puisqu'il a battu
aussi jean pierre chevènement il avait
fait deux nuls contre tienne maquereau
ou en simultané oui donc on me disait
tout à l'heure en fait c'est de lui il
n'y avait pas encore réussi à gagner une
partie contre jean becker danse et un
simultané jouer contre les joueurs mais
c'est donc un joueur de d'un très bon
niveau
ah oui c'est clair que j'ai regardé un
peu ces parties contre josé geovanni
justement et la partie se tenait
c'étaient les pièces qu'elle est plus ou
moins au bon endroit
moi je dis pas qu'il ya pas d
imperfections en tout cas les parties
étaient assez
on sentait qu'ils les bases étaient
bonnes et qu'il y avait un peu
d'originalité en plus alors pour
organiser donc un événement comme ça et
donc une opération parce qu'il s'agit de
placer des tables qui sont maintenant
présentes tous les jours au jardin du
luxembourg
il fallait des organisateurs des gens
qui avec l'idée de le faire et donc il
s'agit de bertrand guyard et en guyane
et de yves marek qui est au sénat donc
mais on va voir tout de suite voilà une
interview des deux organisateurs des
deux initiateurs en fait du projet
bertrand billard et donc yves marek
organisateurs
bourg dans les jardins du sénat aux
échecs et ça fait des années que
j'attrape des scolioses alors ça fait
des années que je me disais ça serait
bien qu'on est très beau et l'échec et
j'ai on en parlait on en parlais avec
mon ami yves marek et un jour il a été
nommé conseiller du président du sénat
et ce rêve est devenu réalité grâce à
lui mais je crois que c'est la meilleure
chose à faire c'est peut-être lui
demandait de savoir comment il a réussi
à convaincre monsieur ponctuelles
président du sénat de mettre des
échiquiers ici donc monsieur yves marek
vous êtes âpres a apparemment passionné
d'échecs également vous êtes au sénat
alors comment avez vous fait pour
convaincre le président du sénat la
vérité je n'ai eu aucune difficulté
parce que il a trouvé tout de suite
l'idée a tout à fait naturel en dépit du
fait qu'il ne joue pas aux échecs et
donc ça a été très vite je lui ai
proposé la chose mois de mai on a étudié
les tables en juin comme c'est un
matériau très difficile à fabriquer il a
bien fallu deux mois pour le faire elle
était sèche à peu près vers le 10
septembre et on les installe aujourd'hui
le 21 d'accord et bien en tout cas je
vous félicite tous les deux merci
d'avoir répondu à ces questions et
passion et moyens ça donne une très
belle manifestation
merci donc voilà il voit on arrive pile
poil à la fin notre émission
effectivement une très belle
organisation très bel événement est
maintenant bel endroit paris pour jouer
quand il fait beau oui alors les tables
sont très très jolie moi c'est la
première chose qui m'a frappé
donc c'est des tables on lave linge va
lier l'âge de pierre
oui en tout cas c'est très joli à
entendre et c'est très joli à voir
également
il suffit d'amener ces pièces
puisqu'elles sont pas en libre service
sur l'échiquier et une pendule les
pièces une pendule et on a un très bon
endroit pour jouer avec des tables bien
stable qui pèse 45 kilos quand même donc
on est bien on est bien et on peut donc
aller au jardin du luxembourg dans
l'espace qui entre eux les terrains de
tennis et le palais du sénat
l'espace réservé aux joueurs d'échecs
voilà donc sambourg donc voila nous
arrivons à la fin de diagonale donc le
match bakowski victoire d'alexander
belafkih avec une victoire 1 0 et donc
au sénat
inauguration d'un nouvel espace
échiquéen par christian poncelet et loi
je crois que tu vas probablement partir
en chine à pékin et donc nous nous
revoyons je crois qu'il n'est pas la
semaine prochaine ni la suivons digne
est la suivante donc dans trois semaines
tu reviens et à ce projet je crois que
nous recevons nicolas giffard ne manquez
pas diagonale la semaine prochaine
actualité internationale des échecs sur
canal web
oui
à